everyone has unique depth of knowledge  in certain areas because you've been  alive and your eyes and ears have taken  inputs period Y combinator is one of the  most successful startup investors in  Silicon Valley and they have a very  standard gel structure and they have  criteria for what they look for in  companies and one of the most important  criteria that they look for is past  experience they're okay with somebody  who's super young Etc but they wanna  they want you to have experience in the  industry because there's just so much  ignorance debt that you have to pay down  if you literally know nothing if your  dad was a mechanic you know so much  about cars just by osmosis of being  around a mechanic for 18 years and so I  like to think parent stuff past jobs of  self and current interests and so it's  like of those three things which of  those three buckets do you think you  could help someone do a thing better  foreign